there's a guy named charles herbster
he's running for uh state senate
and uh he's running for for senate well
what is he running for we're gonna
figure out in a second
he has been accused of groping more than
six women and he has been very strongly
endorsed by donald trump vanity fair
piece by best levin
charles herbster insists he's the victim
of a smear campaign trying to destroy
him with lies
best levin writes donald trump isn't
great at a lot of stuff
but one thing he absolutely excels
excels at is endorsing horrible people
for office since 2016 a who's who of
trump-backed candidates has included roy
reportedly banned from the mall more
lauren i'll care my carry my glock to
congress beaubert
herschel if evolution is real why do
apes still exist walker ron don't say
gay desantis mehmet have some snake oil
oz matt human trafficking is fine gates
and mary hitler actually had a good idea
miller
in october a guy running for oh it's
nebraska governor named charles herbster
got himself added to the list
he has a habit of allegedly groping
women the nebraska examiner reported
thursday eight women say herbster groped
them
writing that six women said he touched
them inappropriately when they were
saying hello or goodbye or when posing
for a photograph by his side a seventh
accused the candidate of cornering her
in private and forcibly kissing her
all of the women told the outlet they
were intentionally grabbed not
inadvertently grazed in one particularly
gross incident republican state senator
julie slama said that herbster in the
middle of a crowded room at an event for
the douglas county republican party
reached up her skirt and touched her
inappropriately without her consent
these are allegations folks remember
another person who attended the event
confirmed they saw herbster reach up
slayma's skirt and claimed that he also
groped another woman's butt at the same
event at the same event
the nebraska examiner piece
is quite disturbing republican state
senator and seven other women say
charles herbster groped them he denies
the allegations now remember that
even if you think trump as a business
person is no good you don't like trump's
foreign policy you don't like trump's
views on immigration or whatever
his continued claim to fame and one
often cited by his strongest supporters
is he makes good choices with hiring
he hires the right people he hires the
best people
and
he continues to endorse people accused
of or proven to have said
horrible things
i encourage you to check out the
nebraska examiner article by aaron
sanderford it's very extensive it's very
detailed etc now the biggest frustration
i think that many of us are having at
this point
is that these types of allegations don't
matter
if the electorate that supports you
doesn't care about them or only cares
about them when they are allegations
against democrats and that's basically
what we have seen i mean at this point
i'm i'm curious to hear from people in
the audience
do allegations like this matter at all
anymore trump was accused
you know even the number is a hard
number to say trump was accused
very specifically of what we would call
sexual assault type behaviors by around
a dozen women but then subsequently we
learned about allegations of a more kind
of broader scope
um from more than 40 women
and he talked about grab them by the
you-know-what and all these you just do
it and all these different things
and he was elected president in 2016. he
was he was really elected
uh we could say well part of it was
hillary wasn't a great candidate and you
know these different things but
the side that claims to be about family
values and all these things
has uh
not cared about it
when it's trump and they excuse it away
well hillary's worse or what am i going
to do stay home or those are lies it's
fake news all these different things so
does it even matter when their side is
accused of this stuff and we've also
talked before about how sometimes
to show how much not like them we are
the left sometimes goes overboard i
think the greatest example is the al
franken situation al franken
you know
he he took a distasteful picture
uh and it was inappropriate and it was
wrong and he apologized in all these
different things but immediately many
prominent democrats said al franken must
resign
and he did
and democrats lost what was a good
senator and i'm not defending what al
franken did but i'm pointing out the
scale of what he did is nothing compared
to what many of these republicans have
been accused of or have been proven to
have done
um
and
it may almost be a fault of the left
that it so quickly goes to we're not
going to be like them we're going to
clean house the same way they should be
cleaning house yeah but they're never
going to do it
and uh i don't know what the exact right
balance is to find
but um
they don't seem to care about any of
this stuff and so there's a real
question as to how the left should
manage and react to it let me know your
thoughts i don't i don't know what the
what the right strategy is